all right so I'm going to ask you the
same question yeah
right here so your son say say in
another world another dimension yeah
yeah another son
um and he he said to you I want to get
with this girl I want to couple up with
this girl she's already got a kid she's
already got kids no you're with kids
that's different all right kid all right
it's okay it's okay one kid yeah
what would you say to him would you
um
would you kind of steer him away from
that or would you encourage it
I wouldn't I wouldn't encourage you he's
a man like I said I raised a man it's
down to him so any [ __ ] that happens
with that woman it's down to you don't
come running back to me because by in
your mind in your mind what what do you
think somebody took me somebody took my
mum okay somebody took me and somebody
took my mum and you know why somebody
took me and somebody took my mum because
we are bloody good women with [ __ ]
partners
but sometimes you get the [ __ ] women out
there with good partners that's the
problem most single women out there
they have good men but the women are
[ __ ] partners that is the problem
I was a good woman with a [ __ ] partner
so it wouldn't be a problem to me if you
can find a woman and you think yeah
she's going to be great go ahead but if
she's gonna be a [ __ ] partner don't
bother auntie I had a question for you
and this might be a personal one
you mentioned in terms of abuse in terms
of your relationship obviously I can
talk because I grew up in that so I
understand how domestic violence works
but those warning signs haven't you seen
those warning signs why did you still
decide to have kids with this person you
see that's the difference
my mum and dad I didn't see anything
between them anything between them my
son didn't say anything between me and
his dad he never saw any of it I never
back talked to his dad he never saw any
violence which there was a load of he
became a man and found out who his dad
was and disowned his dad that's his own
choice and I always leave that but too
many single parents do you know what
just because you're a bad father no just
because you're a bad parent
it's because you're a bad partner
doesn't make you a bad parent and too
many women go out there and the man
might be bad for them but he's not bad
for the child
but they were bad took the man to the
child I never did that my mom never did
that we never saw anything and that's
the difference no but I I do hear that
but you didn't quite answer my question
and I agree with what you're saying in
terms of it you know you're telling me
about choosing I can't I didn't right
then normally if you see if somebody
goes into abusively they come from
abusive family they get into an abusive
relationship and it continues I never
knew that my mum was in abusive
relationship
you kind of went for someone like your
father and your father no no no no no no
no no no so for somebody that had
nothing to do with my father because I
didn't know what my father was like I
didn't know that my dad was abusive to
my mum all I knew is that they got
divorced and I blame my mum okay she
never told me why I found out why myself
later on as an adult
so I couldn't say well oh my dad was bad
for my mum I thought myself my mom was a
[ __ ] because she left my dad that was
my dad's favorite not realizing that she
was saving me and saving herself
so it wasn't some people continue I
understand what you're saying some
people continue that cycle so that's
what I'm trying to get to cycle I didn't
continue that cycle because I got in one
of these abusive relationship and that
was it I didn't repeat the cycle but
that was it by what I'm saying it's
still happening obviously I'm assuming
you were with the guy for some time no
no oh so it was a short period no no it
was a long time in the abuse but once I
had my son that was it because my son
comes first yeah what I'm saying is wait
up to the point of you having a child
they would have been warning signs what
made you not think oh you know what this
guy is a bit tapped you try getting
locked up in a room and 10 floors up and
somebody's telling you the only way out
is over the balcony do you think you're
gonna leave
um
this is before no this is when this is
when during it was always an abusive
relationship and the difference is is
that if my dad had been there it
wouldn't have happened
that's the only difference if my dad had
been there it wouldn't have happened but
you get people out there that pray
on
girls out there because they know they
have no fathers because the things that
happen to me if my dad was there I'm not
saying that he had to stay with my mum
but Effie was there regularly
somebody I can go and talk to and say
well this is happening and he would have
stepped up but he was never there he was
never there for me to turn to there was
nobody there for me to turn to so I just
dealt with it the best that I could but
yes they did new [ __ ] they
children need fathers but they need good
Fathers and there's no point staying in
a relationship just for the sake of a
relationship when your child is going to
be a detriment it's always best for your
child my mum chose what's best for a
child I chose what's best for my child
if my father was there it wouldn't have
happened it would not have happened let
me just do everything yeah I was going
to say but if you need to jump I was
going to say one point quickly hold on
hold on yeah go ahead go go ahead go
ahead good all right let me just let me
ask this question because I wanna you
know it's turned into a little back and
forth let me just get everyone involved
yeah all right so I want to kind of jump
off what you was talking about and I
want to go around and ask people like
why do you think that the rate of single
mothers has gone up like who like what
is the cause of it what do you think is
causing so many women to end up being
you know without a man there in the
house
okay that's a very good question
um
um and it's a tough one but I do think
us woman we tend to create sort of an
illusion
and kind of fall in love with it like a
future image
and not really realize that we are not
with the right partner before we
actually get a kid
and
I think people end up being single first
of all because when they have a child it
changes both people
so I can absolutely relate for
uh for Auntie when she was saying that
she had the kids and then obviously his
partner was very abusive and so they
have to break up just to be sure that
it's gonna be better for everyone but
it's not it basically she cannot
necessarily see and I don't mean to be
um offensive or anything but she not
necessarily can see that science
beforehand because when you have a kid
it changes everything so I think that's
also one of the reason why there are so
many single womans with the kid because
they either do it too soon like they
think they might can have a kid because
they are in that moment in love and they
think yeah you know let's have a kid
because it would be fun some people do
it for money like in my country uh you
get like a really big amount of benefit
if you have a kid and the more you have
the more money you get and people don't
actually think in the future that you
just loaded in depth because you have to
pay that back oh no I want to jump on
what you said initially and you said um
women see like a certain like fairy tale
image of the guy most of them before
like it gets serious and then the guy
ends up actually showing his true colors
because in my opinion I feel like women
are really bad at choosing men like
consistently make poor choices in men in
in the first place you know what I'm
saying and then you know whatever re
whatever it is that attracted the woman
to the man should kind of hold on to
that no no regardless of as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible